en esta clínica de Shanghai los recién
nacidos son mimados un equipo de
expertos cuida a 15 bebés en un país que
cada vez tiene menos la tasa de
fertilidad nunca había sido tan baja en
China 1,16 hijos por mujer frente al
promedio mundial de 2,3 eres muy tierno
un bebé con ojos grandes
para esta partera el descenso de los
nacimientos es alarmante
es preocupante que los jóvenes ya no
quieran tener hijos porque el país está
envejeciendo y Eso provoca una presión
en la sociedad
las autoridades abolieron la política
del hijo único hace siete años pero esta
dejó su huella hoy en día los chinos
pueden tener dos o incluso tres hijos
pero para muchos esto es impensable
Juan acaba de dar a luz a una niña Este
Será su único bebé
por ahora no he pensado en tener un
segundo hijo porque la suciedad es
bastante cruel con las madres
trabajadores no es nada fácil ocuparse
de uno mismo de su familia y de su
carrera
en 2021 solo se registraron 10,6
millones de nacimientos en China casi la
mitad que hace 10 años la principal
razón es el costo de la educación según
un estudio educar un hijo hasta la
mayoría de edad cuesta en promedio
76.000 euros una de las cifras más altas
del mundo tener dos hijos es un signo de
riqueza Este es el caso de la familia Fu
cómo te fue hoy teníamos que hacer un
discurso el tema era Qué harías si
tuvieras mucho dinero Ryan y Kylie
estudian en una de las mejores escuelas
secundarias de la capital lo que
representa 14.000 euros al año por cada
uno y fuera de la escuela su agenda es
igual de apretada hoy tienen clases de
programación tienen clases de
programación y después sus clases de
baile de dibujo de matemáticas y también
entrenamiento de hockey En total son
unos 2.800 euros al mes
una inversión para su futuro
acá están todos nuestros trofeos y
diplomas
a sus 14 años el hijo mayor ya se
esfuerza por alcanzar la Excelencia
en mi escuela la mayoría de los Niños
Son muy inteligentes estudian mucho no
soy tan bueno como ellos y todavía tengo
que trabajar duro para ponerme al día
con un hijo más Esta carrera hacia la
Excelencia sería imposible hoy en día
para darle una buena educación a un hijo
Es cierto que los gastos son elevados es
necesario porque la sociedad actual es
muy competitiva No creo que pudiera
cuidar bien a un tercer hijo con 12
suficiente
el inminente descenso de la población no
podría amenazar el crecimiento de China
y eso les preocupa a las autoridades en
la inauguración del vigésimo Congreso
Nacional el mismo chilling ping hizo al
partido comunista a abordar el problema
pondremos en marcha medidas políticas
para impulsar la natalidad
y aplicaremos una estrategia nacional
para hacer frente al envejecimiento de
la población
para este especialista ya es demasiado
tarde Lleva años advirtiendo que la
crisis demográfica es inminente
las autoridades escucharon nuestras
advertencias pero no nos creyeron lo que
llevó a un grave error de cálculo las
medidas actuales del gobierno pero como
la construcción de un gran número de
guarderías y en la entrega de algunos
subsidios No son suficientes para frenar
la tendencia a la baja de los
nacimientos
el número de matrimonios también está
disminuyendo solo 7,6 millones este año
un mínimo histórico desde 1986 la
generación más joven se casa más
tardíamente o no se casa para disgusto
de sus mayores Este es el mercado de
bodas de Shanghai los padres
desesperados publican los currículos de
sus hijos para encontrarles un alma
gemela para ellos no formar familia es
inconcebible cuando una chica crece a
partir de los 24 o 25 años se supone que
debe encontrar a alguien casarse formar
una familia tener hijos para que sirve
una mujer que no se casa a los 50 años
Quién va a quererla después de los 25
años a las mujeres se les llama signos
mujeres sobrantes las jóvenes chinas
rechazan cada vez más estas etiquetas
sijin y Yolanda forman parte de un grupo
de apoyo profesional para mujeres para
ellas sus carreras son lo primero
prefiero tener más tiempo para mí y para
Son nuevos conocimientos o desarrollar
más habilidades
eligen la independencia a pesar de la
presión social
mi mamá me dijo que para que su vida
estuviera completa Tengo que casarme y
tener hijos
Así que eso me pone una presión enorme
no planeo tener hijos y aunque algún día
me case realmente quiere estar en una
pareja sin hijos
este descenso de la natalidad está
acelerando un envejecimiento de la
población china un tercio de la
población tendrá más de 60 años en 2035
y para ese mismo año se prevé que el
sistema de pensiones esté en déficits